In Sodden,
we banded together
to fight not only
for the future of magic,
but for the future
of the Continent.
Our victory came at a great cost.
Today,
we must unite
against a common enemy.
This is what strength looks like.
Yennefer of Vengerberg
survived fire magic.
Yennefer has only ever
known magic.
She is powerful and unpredictable.
And as a consequence
of using fire magic,
she is wanted.
But she's been captured.
Do you really think
offering me as a sacrifice
will be enough
to spare your failure?
I know that my faith
brought me this far.
I'll see how much further
it can take me.
Fringilla doesn't
leave anything unturned.
She knows she needs
to rebuild an army
and she knows
she's gonna come back.
We won, but barely.
We don't know the troops
that Nilfgaard have in reserve.
Tissaia, she has a very strong idea
of what is the right thing to do.
What's motivating her is to try
and shift the balance of power.
The hero kills the enemy.
For her, it's very much a battle
between good and evil.
What a welcome sight.
Surprise.
Triss is definitely a powerful mage.
But she's looking for
that human connection,
and that seems to coincide
with Geralt needing a bit of help
at Kaer Morhen.
I brought her here
to help guide you.
I have a friend
who studies monoliths.
I think in a world
with so much violence,
a character like Istredd
is refreshing.
There's a mystery there.
He's one step ahead of the game.
His journey is kind of dictated
by trying to find out
about the monolith
and how they all link.
They hold the history
of this Continent.
And I think
they hold our future too.
At least conjure me up
some decent food
before we get to to Shitgaard.